In this game dev course varnas games will teach
you how to build games with Unreal Engine five,
you will also learn how to use the blueprint
visual scripting system that makes it simpler
to create gameplay elements. Hey, guys, thank
you so much for checking this course out.
This is going to be a very, very beginner level,
Unreal Engine five blueprints only course,
we're going to make a simple game called
the battery man. So if I play this game,
what's going to happen is I have a few batteries
present all around the scene, I have to collect
these batteries over here. And once that's done, I
either go to the new level, or I win the game. So
here, this is my second level. And if I collect
these batteries, I have my event condition. And
I always have a loose condition too. So if I wait
it out, if I don't collect any of these batteries
over here, and wait for five seconds, I lose the
game, I can quit if I want. And if I can retry,
we obviously still we have made many too. So we're
going over everything in this game, including
UI validate taking a look at when conditions and
emissions. We're coding everything from scratch,
we're using the Third Person template, but
we're not using any of their built in movement,
we're going to create our own character
add our own functionality to these
to this character. So it's going
to be a game that you have.
Hey, guys, and welcome back. Now we
will take a look at Unreal Engine five
and try to create our own project. So what you
have to do is open up your Epic Games launcher.
And Epic Games launcher is essentially a poster to
Unreal Engine and its marketplace. So if I'm if I
let's take a look at the marketplace over
here. So the marketplace essentially has
all these different high quality assets
that I can use. And one thing I love about
the marketplace is that has something called
the free for the month five, where it chooses
five paid assets from the asset store from the
marketplace. And it provides the users of Unreal
Engine these assets for absolutely free. So that
is an amazing feature. And that's why I love
the Unreal Engine marketplace. It has
a lot of different high quality assets,
and even Epic Games, most of it, most of the
content Epic Games provides is completely free
and you can use it in your game. So try check
out the marketplace and use this in your game.
It's not cheating, it's actually an amazing thing
that you do know how to use other people's assets
on your game, because that's how game development
actually works. Let's try and see how to install
Unreal Engine five. Now, if I open up the games
launcher and open this up five part over here,
it has my early it says Unreal Engine five early
access. Now Unreal Engine five is not complete,
which is why it still says it's an early access.
But I can download my early access from here. And
I can also get the sample project that that they
showed in the Unreal Engine five showcase video,
which is amazing. But once you're once you're
done installing Unreal Engine file, if you go to
your library, you will see your Unreal Engine
five editor over here and I can open it up.
And over here. If you scroll all the way down, if
you go to Wall, you have all of the assets that
you bought or claim I have all of these assets,
all of these are free assets and they're amazing.
So try to check the assets out
maybe you might like something and
make them outfit. Anyways, I can go here and
hit launch. And if it takes a while Don't worry,
I have my Android version five installed on my
HDD just because of how big it is. Usually I
have the engine on my HDD and then on my SSD is
where I have all of my project saved. So you can
do that you can have the same approach or you can
do something different it's completely up to you.
But that's usually what I do. It takes a it takes
a long time to open up Unreal Engine for me,
essentially because of because I mean one
I'm recording and two because of the fact
that for Unreal Engine you need pretty decent
specs I have like average specs for example you
can see I have a six core CPU and memory when
it comes to memory. If you're trying to make
a game using Unreal Engine make sure you have at
least 16 GB RAM. Don't try to create a game with
eight GB it is not going to work out well for you
especially if it's going to be a high scale game.
And make sure you have a good graphics card. I
have two GB RAM so I can barely get through this.
But if you if you're trying to if you're
purchasing a new laptop or a new computer just
for game development, make sure you have a good
CPU which is six cores at least or more than six
cores. It uses a lot of CPU power. So if I go to
processes over here you can see Unreal Engine is
hogging up my CPU like crazy. And if I go to my
performance again, memory, make sure you have like
at least 16 GB RAM, especially on the engine five,
you will not be able to get when I swear to God.
But anyways, let's go to games. And but we
have a lot of these templates over here.
So if you want to create a really quick prototype,
the best part about Unreal Engine is that you can
create prototypes really easily. So if I
want to create a first person prototype,
I can, instead of creating the movement, the
projectile movement, everything from scratch,
I can just I can just use the template over
here, and it will create it automatically for me.
So I have my shooting part, my keyboard, my, my
joystick all of them built in, so I don't have
to create it from scratch. Now this this is
very, very useful when it comes to game jams,
necessarily you game jams or competitions, where
you are given like a day or two days to create
a game. And for those, it's very, very useful.
So you can see I have a lot of these different
projects, I'm going to be using third person,
except we're going to create the animations,
the game, whether the movement logic, everything
from scratch. So that's what I'm going to use the
third person and the reason why I'm using third
person. Third Person project and not a blank
project is because I have a lot of Unreal Engine
provides a lot of animations. And I need these
animations in my game, I don't want to make my
animations from scratch, which is fine, I'm going
to use the third person project. Now under quality
patient, I'm going to use change mine to scalable,
I'm going to enable static content static
content essentially like a bunch of assets
Unreal Engine gives for free like textures,
materials, particles, etc. Under project name,
make sure there's no blueprint, not C++, there
is not a C++ close, there is not a C++ course,
the next the next course that I'll be releasing,
that's going to be a C++ course of the same game.
Anyway, so I'm going to name this Batman
and create project, this might take a while,
especially if it's your first time, this
might take a while for me not much. But
when it's compiling shaders, that's when
it takes a very long time. So if you have,
if you have a project that has a lot of different
gameplay logic and assets built into it,
then it is going to take a very, very long time,
especially because it has to compile the shaders.
Okay, now now that it's open up, you can see
that we have this scene and all everyone opens
up the third person scene. This is the default
scene over here, I have the the floors, there's
a lot of cubes, the character, blah, blah, blah.
Let's start to go over all of these one by one.
Now I have to place actors tab where I
have different confidence or actors that
I can add on to my scene, what is an actor,
an actor is an object that can be placed
on the world. This is an empty act. And I
can then add logic to this act over here.
Now how this works is that everything that can
be placed onto the scene is an actor. So the
box trigger is essentially an actor. Look at it
this way. A Tesla Model S for example, is a car.
It is an electric car, but still a car It derives
from a car. That's how this works over here. The
Empty Actor is universal everything that can be
placed over here as an actor. So this is an actor,
this is an actor, but we have different types
of actors. So from an actor, something called
upon is created upon as an actor that can be
processed, processed, meaning it can you can
add input actor to this to this point over here,
for example, you can move the point like a vehicle
etc. Or character is basically attack upon that
move around. So this is how the hierarchy works.
You have an active force, under this actor, we
have a point so the point inherits from an actor,
and the character inherits from a point and
basically has like mesh collision, etc. Let's
talk about collision Shelby, select this third
person character and in the World Outliner, you
can see that this third person character has been
selected. And under world settings, I have my game
mode override. We'll take a look at all of this
later. But let's go to a Details panel. Underneath
this panel, I have my capsule component, which
is basically collision. The way collision
works in games is that you have a capsule you
don't have all these complex collisions, like
you know the exact shape of the character
that is not going to happen. It's very,
very resource hungry. We use simple collisions
in our games. And what permissions do is it
makes sure it doesn't walk through the stairs
over here unless you want to create a ghost.
I can move up the stairs I can Jump um
solid the collision basically says okay this
object is solid, but that does not make collision
cannot be you know collision cannot be cannot
walk through the wall it definitely can you have
different presets. For example, I can save my I
can set my collision in such a way that I can move
through stairs, but I cannot move through a floor,
I can do that, I can definitely do that, all
you have to do is select the capsule component.
And once you select the capsule component,
and in this part over here we have different
other we have different attributes essentially
like the transform the shape, the navigation,
all of that. Now, the transform is universal for
every single game engine, we have the location,
the rotation and the scale. The red is for the x
axis, y is for them in the green is for Y axis and
the blue for the Zed axis. You can also see these
arrows over here. If I change this red arrow,
if I hold this red arrow and like my mouse,
you can see that my x axis is getting changed
the same for my Y and my said, I can also move
two axes at the same time. For example, my Zed
oops, okay, that's pretty good. I can move my
Zed and my bi axes at the same time. Really,
okay, I know what I'm going to move my x and my
y, just because it's simple, you can see that
my values, the corresponding values also change.
So I'm that then when you're trying to place
objects, that is you'll sort of have to
understand how to change all of these
values. Now I can also change the rotation, if I
press E, I can change my rotation. So you can see
I can go up and down, I can change, for example.
Okay, let's let's actually go back. If I, if I
change the green part over here, you can see them
changing by rotation with respect to my y axis,
same goes to the blue and the red does
not waste time. And the scale is obviously
the size of the character, I'm going to
change this back to zero, I don't want
a humongous character. Okay, now mine is
supposed to be one non zero, if it's zero,
it's going to be it's not going to have the x
dimension at all, it's going to be a two that it's
going to be a two dimensional object, capsule
component if I have something called mobility,
and this is present for every single object.
So for example, if I select my network,
the Mac, the star, play Star, essentially, it
defines where my player should start, this is
for the SS network player starts. So that's for
multiplayer. So this capsule, probably under
capsule company, if I have if I have something on
mobility, it I can basically say if my character
should be static, mobile or stationary. If I'm
if my character person gets some input and has
to move in one of these accesses, or even rotate,
I need to make sure that is movable. Over here,
I have my animations, we'll be going over all of
this later on be recreating this from scratch,
I have my mesh, I can select if I want to simulate
physics or not. And that gives realistic physics,
I can enable gravity or disable
gravity. Actually, you know what,
try to change all these values and try to see
what it does. That's the best way to learn to just
explore the explore and try to change all these
values. Hopefully you don't break the engine.
I have my capsule competence. So I basically have
different competence attached to my character. And
these confidence have different attributes like
my for example, my hair has different attributes
by my legs have different attributes, but as
a whole person. So that is basically how this
works. It as a whole is a third person character
and has different components attached to it,
a hammer camera, etc. Now, you can see that
it says it's inherited over here, it means
my if I hover over this, it says my parent classes
character, What in hell would I mean by inheriting
means this actually a programming concept. And
what this means is that the parent class has a
set of attributes that I inherit on my child, this
is this third person character, this is not this,
this inherits from the character class. So you
can see the pen class it says the character class
and the character class has the capsule component,
the mesh, etc. So I don't have to if I create a
child of this third person, character, I mean the
child of this character class and have all of the
all of this melted. Think of this as you think
of your parents. If you're if your parents have,
let's say, brown eyes, the chances of you
having blue eyes is pretty pretty low. So
you kind of inherit the genes from your parents,
and it's getting passed on to the child. That's
how programming works too. And that's why it's so
beautiful. Now when it comes to content browser,
I have my blueprints and with the content
boxes used to navigate through your game files
And that's pretty much what it's used for. And I
have different folders. This has been created by
Unreal Engine automatically because of what
template I've chosen. So if I go to blueprints,
I have a third person character. Before that,
let's first familiarize ourselves with the place
actors Part Two, if I go to, I have different
tabs over here under place actors, I have my
directional light, my point light over here, sport
light, all of that just like real life, I can,
I can drag drag this value into the scene, and it
has automatically selected whatever object I've
added, I can change all of these values, for
example, I can change the light color to like,
an a blue, red, etc, I can change my intensity,
I can either make an absolutely bright or very,
very dark. So the C D stands for CAD,
CAD, do whatever, okay, I don't know,
I started physics. But anyways, that's what
intensity is for my attenuation radius, that's
all of these are physics light concepts. So if you
really liked physics, you'd probably be able to
recognize all of these different variables
over here. Unfortunately, if you want to get
really good game development, a little bit of
physics, a little bit of math, it is important,
because, you know, programming is essentially just
math, and physics, but in a very, very practical
bill. So did you don't need to know math,
physics and all of that. But it does help a lot.
You can understand the concepts a lot better,
especially when you have to debug something or
add a completely new feature. Anyways, let's
not waste any more time. And that's create a
new level so that we can add our own characters,
I mean, our own objects to the scene. The fact
if I click on my file, I can go to new level,
I'm going to create a default level over here,
and it'll automatically ask me to save this model
over here. Now, if I press Ctrl S, I can save this
on my folder, I'm going to create like click
over here create a new folder called scenes.
And I'm going to call this level one.
Actually, this should be called levels,
I used to do this in Unity a lot. It's supposed
to be levels in Unity two, three policies.
There we go. Okay, I'm going to remove the
floor and the Player Start that they actually
Yeah, put it over the place, we will add all
of this. I have, obviously I have something
called atmospheric fog, which variable has a
lot of influence on light. But I can also add
something called the exponential height fog
with, which adds a lot of depth to the map.
Actually try to try to explore over here try to
add different objects onto your scene, as I said,
but we'll be creating something called a landscape
over here. So I have something called landscape
tab. If I click on this, you have something, okay.
All of these clients that you see over here, this
is usually called gizmos in game development. This
applies for all all game engines, these lines,
the basic call gizmos, and they're basically
outlines of whatever object you have selected.
The reason why I'm painting the landscape and
just not adding a cube over here and scaling it
is because it is very, very well optimized
landscapes are optimized for huge, huge levels.
And I'll actually show you why. Over here, if
I go to my landscape tab, I can change a lot
of different values. But all I'm going to worry
about as my section size, I'm going to make the
seven to seven chords. So you can see it's seven
over here and seven over here, I guess 1234 Yep,
there we go. And I am going to create this. Now
the reason why I say this is very well optimized
is first off, I can change the depth of this
landscape and you will see in just a second.
Oh, I forgot to add the material, but
no probably we can add that later on.
It might take a while if
especially if it's the first time
for to set everything up. But once you've
had created this, this wait for a bit
okay, you can now see this huge white cursor over
here. Let's change the brush size to something
small. You can see that I've selected it has
automatically selected the sculpt part and I can
basically add some depth to this map. For example,
I can create mountains over here and if I want to
flatten it, I can select the flattened part
and then completely flat smoothen this out
and flatten this to do the reverse of Actually
no. Now this automatically selects the sculpt
part here. I can basically create mountains
etc. Smoother where it is pretty surface
mount is more than sit out. And you can see that
the shadows start disappearing. And it's kind
of the opposite of sculpt mode. Flatten makes
the land as flat as possible. So if I want to,
like, add a river over here, I don't know
if you guys are aware, but Unreal Engine has
this amazing water system. So if I want to add a
component, not a river, that doesn't make sense,
if I want to add a point over here, I can easily
do that. But the reason why I'm using landscape
is because let me show you something. Let's
actually go all the way. Let's cut this part
over here. And let me change the tool strength
to like point four. So it's faster, you can
see that it does not render the graphics over
here, because it does not have to like, I mean,
why would I want to render all of my graphics is
the depth, the complete height of this graphics
over here, when the player is not going to see
it? Right? It's all about optimization. Now,
this is also one of the reasons why you've seen
in many games, if you have some collision issues,
for example, if I don't have collision over here,
and the player just sort of falls through the map,
if you keep falling, you can actually notice that
you won't be able to see the top of the level.
That is because of the optimization part of this
landscape or whatever they using. It applies
to a lot different game engines. It was very,
very common in Grand Theft Auto, San Andreas,
and also cyberpunk. But anyways, that's pretty
much why I'm using landscape. So here and also
because I can use the the sculpt feature here, let
me just, I'm going to add some depth, I'm going to
make this look like an actual ground so that it's
not completely flat, I find that really boring
I hate I hate when objects are completely flat.
So I'm just sort of going to do that. And let's,
so you can see that it's it's editing something
called the height map, the height map essentially
adds depth tells the map where how high. The level
is, for example, this coordinate my, I have like
mountain of some sort. And we here I don't. So
that's pretty much what it's doing, we're here.
Now if I want to go back to my SELECT mode, I
can just simply click on my select modal here.
And that is pretty much it. So if I select my
landscape, I can change a lot of these values,
what I'm gonna do is I'm actually going to create
this again, because I didn't show you how to add
a material. So when you go to your landscape
mode, you can see this material part over here,
try to select the ground material. And let's
create it again. And it's going to be 77.
So that's how you add material. And again,
I'm going to add some depth over here, just
rub sound and make sure you have you click your
mouse and just to wrap this around. Okay, that
is awesome. Now they've created the landscape. And
also another good part about this landscape mode
is that it scales the texture automatically
for you so that it's not just, you know,
one part of the texture, it sort of scales a lot.
So I really, really love that about the landscape.
So try to add some lights onto your landscape,
try to experiment on your own to change the light,
the color of the light or the intensity, whatever
you want. And that less and less, I think around
the exponential height fog. If I go all
the way to the top, I could change the
fog density to make this really foggy. I
want to give this a sort of Martian like,
looks, I'm sort of gonna make that red in
color. And yeah, that looks really good.
Okay, now, let's get into the coding part. But
it's not exactly coding. It's called something
called blueprinting. And that's the visual
scripting language of Unreal Engine and I
absolutely love it. If you go to the Blueprints
folder, you can see the third person character
that says W tech. Now remember, this does not mean
you can completely get away with just blueprints.
You will need C++ if you're making a full fledged
game and releasing it. Why because blueprints are
mostly meant for prototyping and small features.
If you if you have if you're trying to make a
multiplayer game, for example, you can't get
away with blueprints because blueprints is not
exactly the fastest programming language. It is
also a programming language, but it's not fast.
C++ is a lot faster, which is why we're going to
create the exact same game game in C++ later on.
But that is a different course. This is only
going to be blueprints as I explained before.
This might seem a little confusing for you, but
actually these are two different windows And
if I go to my viewport over here, I can see
my third person character in action. And I
can see my collide, I can see all of my confidence
altogether, like the camera, the error component,
all of that, let's try to take a look at all of
these one by one, they've always taken a look at
the capsule component, let's take a look at the
arrow confident this basically points towards the
points to the front of me to the forward
vector, or it points forward all the time. They
say look at the mesh, the mesh. Okay, so now we
have two different types of mesh in Unreal Engine,
whereas the static mesh, and one is in skeletal
mesh, the Static Mesh is used for stuff like,
let's say, a cube, for example, if I drag this
cube over here, you can see I have a static mesh.
That's mostly because this cube is probably
not going to move and it does not have any
extra animations. Like, I mean, what am I going to
animate out of cute, maybe I can make this fall,
it's a champion, I don't need a skeleton, I don't
need something called a skeleton for it. But I
have something called the Skeletal Mesh. And this
is the complex counterpart for the Static Mesh. A
Skeletal Mesh is essentially a mesh with something
called a skeleton, the how animations are created
is you have something called a skeleton and it's
assigned to a particular mesh. And you have the
skeleton is of a bone and riddlin. It's almost
just like the human, the human skeleton over here.
Now, what how animations are created is i You
take specific bone, and you sort of change
the values. For example, if I rotate this bone
over here, activate an animation, I mean this
for a second slapping someone, but that's pretty
much how animations are created. I manipulate the
transform values of this of these points over
here, like, okay, not the middle finger, maybe
the index finger. And yeah, there we go, I can
do that. So that's pretty much what animations,
how animations are created. Now you can create
animations in Unreal Engine, but I'd suggest you
to if you want to learn how to make animations,
there are a lot of Blender courses online,
by Game Dev TV, or anyways, there are a lot of
different there's a lot of Blender courses online,
please take a look at it. It's amazing. But this
is the skeleton that unreal provides us with,
I have something for the camera, boom. Now, if I
hover over it, this is the spring arm component.
And the spring arm component. Essentially, the
reason why we're not adding the camera directly
is because if I have a wall behind, and if
my if my character is moving behind him, if
characters moving back like that, okay hadn't
moved the capsule, I've actually moved the mesh,
if I keep moving back and the camera moves with
it, the camera might flip through the wall,
I don't want that I want my camera to sort of move
up as the wall as I'm getting closer to the wall,
which is what Sprayground is used for it makes
sure that you the camera doesn't move through
the void. Now the follow camera is that the camera
itself and if you want to change the position add
rather change the values of the target offset over
here. So five, Jesus like maybe 30, I mean 300,
you can see moves with respect to the y axis. So
I do it that way, anytime. So I'm going to if I
want this hire, I can change the socket offset,
and then press E change the rotation like that.
So that's the way to go when it comes to making
a camera system. And they have the character
movement. This is a built in component created by
and created by Epic Games. And this basically has
different menus that you can manipulate, for
example, the movement values, let's actually
try to change these if I search for my walk speed
over here, that's actually search for the maximum
walk speed. If I change this to like, let's say
350 over here. And if you want your changes to
get saved, you have to make sure you hit on the
compile button. And if I press Alt P, you can
see that I am walking slower than usual. So I can
basically manipulate all of these values. And this
is again, you can see that is inherited.
So this belongs to the character class.
And this character class has all of these
inherited so I can read any of these. Let's,
let's respect the 600. But anyways, it doesn't
matter because we're creating our own character.
The Event Graph is where you create your
logic. So these are all called nodes. And
you can basically drag and drop these nodes
over here to create your flow of the code.
Don't worry, this is very confusing. We'll be
creating all of this from scratch. Okay, and yeah,
that's pretty much it for the Event Graph. And if
I go to my Construction Script This occurs even
before the even before the game starts. So if I
want to add some functionality to my game engine,
I can do that in the Construction Script. In
my event graph, I have my variables button.
Let's take a look at the graphs, I can get
different graphs. For example, I can create a new
graph just a moment, if I want to keep this very,
very tidy. But we're not going to do that we have
a very simple script, so that's fine. And we have
something called variables a variable is okay,
I'm going to make a variable that a variable is
basically something that can contain a value.
Variables can be of different types,
floats, integers, integer 64, by double,
let's take a look at all of these. A boolean holds
a true or false value by the snake bit number,
integer is a number bigger than the byte integer
6464. bit number float is a decimal number. So
that's like 3.14 10.6 6.9. And double is a
big 64 bit floating floating point numbers
as far as like 6.999. And and then try and
keep going on until six bits of memory.
A name is a piece of text, or string is basically
any single value that's in quotes. For example,
it could be my name, or the the word, the
word hello, or the sentence Hello world,
that could be a string. A text as well, this is
a different type of string used for UI, etc. Name
is mostly used for scene names, level names, all
of that vector, a vector in physics is basically
a value that has a magnitude and direction. So
I can say, x is moving at 10 to 10 meters square
per second in my in the x direction. So that's a
vector. And a vector consists of the X, Y and Zed
values to theta is for rotation, and
it also has the X, Y and Zed values
that are transformed. We've already seen it, it's
the rotation, the rotation location and the scale.
It is universal for every single game engine. So
yeah, that is the basics for the blueprints. Now
let's go ahead and create our own character.
So I'm going to create a new folder first. And
I'm going to call this custom blueprints,
because I will differentiate between the
ones that Epic Games has created and the ones
that I've created. And it's very important to
be organized. Now. Okay, trust me on this, every
single game developer will ask you to be organized
and they themselves will not be organized. This
happens all the time. But it is best practices,
you're just starting to learn. Try, keep your
project as organized as possible. Now, over here,
I have my desktop icons, hidden but if I showed
you your policy, how old next time, make sure
you don't make that mistake, try to organize
your folders as much as possible. And custom
blueprints, I'm going to create a Blueprint Class,
and this is going to inherit from my character. So
I'm going to have every single functionality
that this character provides. For example, I can
walk around, I can add input the code, I have the
ability to do that. But I need to make sure I tell
my character to move that's like you, you have the
intelligence to make game. But you need to learn
how to make a game that's pretty much what we're
doing over here. So have a character, I can select
that. And the naming convention is usually DT
underscore the name someone call this battery man.
And if I open it up, I don't have the mesh
anything. So if I go to my third person character
and try to compare it all of these inherited
parts, I have them on my VPN disco Batchi. Man,
I don't have the mesh because the mesh isn't I
mean, I don't have the camera and the spring on
component because that is not inherited. So let's
actually copy this and add them to our character
over here. Oh, actually seems like yeah, we can
probably them coffee and paste them over here.
So I already have my camera added or you can just
say Add Camera and add spring on component etc.
Okay, I have my camera, Compile and Save and let's
assign our mesh. So if I go to my mesh, I can go
to my skeletal mesh. I have only two of these.
I have the female and the male. I'm going to use
the male mannequin. They're going to bring this
all the way to the bottom by 80 units. Actually,
let's do 90 Actually, no, I think I think it
would be fine over here and press E and let's
move that by 90 degrees. And again, that's the Zed
axis companion save that style. To run the game,
you will notice that I still have my third person
character. And if you're still confused as to
what character I'm using, you can inject
from this character. What does that mean?
function, just press f8 in your keyboard.
And then you can the game is still running,
but I can basically debug the scene over here.
Now if you select your third person character,
you can see that I'm still using metal first
character, my player since pawn. And that sparks
a question. How does the game engine know without
adding any functionality? How does this know that
I am adding I want my third person character
to spawn? That doesn't even make sense, right?
The reason is because I have something called
game modes. If you go to Edit Project Settings,
let's take a look at the maps and modes part.
Over here, I have something called Game Mode, the
game would basically set default values for every
single scene. So I can say, no matter what scene I
create, I always want my third person character to
spawn. And in that scene, I can say for example,
if it's the main menu, I can have an override
game mode, which says, Okay, for the main menu,
don't spawn the character, because that's
weird. So I'm going to just have my UI, etc,
I don't want my character to respond. So that's
how Unreal engine works. So over here, on my
default game mode, I'm going to change this value
to BP underscore Batman. And now if I press Alt P,
I can see over here, but obviously, I don't
have any functionality. The reason is,
because I have the ability to take input, but
I haven't done anything with that input yet.
So that's what we're going to add over here. If I
go to my event graph, let's actually take a look
at all of these events over here, which we haven't
seen before. I'm going to remove these. Okay, now,
the event claim, let's actually see what this
does the event play event, it executes whatever
code that's attached to it in the beginning of
the game, so only one is going to get executed
once and that's when you begin playing the game.
Even take it gets executed every single second.
And let's actually take a look at an example. If
I drag this over here is called the exec node.
And I can release it to play to place a new
node. And I can just save print string over here.
The way this works is, when I call begin play when
they implement is called automatically and that
time is going to print out the string over here.
And I'm just going to say this is they can play
compile, and let's play the game, Alt P. And you
can see that says this, this is being played. Now,
I'm going to add Player Start at the play style
essentially defines where my player stood bed, my
ventilation stopped the game. So now I don't fall
off the map. So notice this is big and played.
I'm going to now press Alt and
click this button over here.
And then move on move this to the bottom, and
then drag the event take note over here. Now this
can be anywhere. But I'm just I just asked you to
get it bring it to the bottom because I want this
to be neat. So Compile and Save on dpi. And now
you can see that printed every single frame. Now
remember, this might be different for every single
computer. If my game runs at 60 frames per second,
this function will be called 60 frames per second.
But in a different person's computer, let's say
you have an RTX 13 3080. And your game runs at
like 160 frames per second 120 frames per second,
then this function will be called at 100 120
frames per second. That is how the tick function
works. For unity users. This is like the start
and the update functions. Very, very similar.
So we're not actually not going to use any of
these because what we're going to do is we're
going to say if I press my W key or my s or my
A or my D, do me move the character and if I
press let's say my mouse button, print something
out, that's what we're going to say over here. So
if I minimize this window, go to
Edit Project Settings. I have my
input part over here. I have two types of
bindings over here. One is the action binding
action mapping and once the Axis Mapping action
mappings are pretty self explanatory, I just have
my spacebar over here. I'm actually not going
to bother adding bank our game does not have
any jumping mechanics over here so we're not going
to add any jump but I'll actually show you how to
make your player jump. So this basically says if
I if I'm basically if I go back to my blueprint,
right like and Jump event. You can see under input
action events, I have this jump, and this button,
my press my button, press my jump button, do
something, press. If I release my jumper do
something, I was the jump button. The jump button
is my spacebar. And for my gamepad, it's my face,
pop, pop bottom. But anyways, I'm going to
name all of these Unreal Engine, obviously,
it seems like it supports a lot of different
consoles, which is awesome. And my access
mappings, this gets a little confusing, I'm going
to remove everything I'm not going to use again,
because it gets very confusing for new developers.
So I'm going to do more of these. Now, if I press
W, I want to return a value of one, which is
basically going forward. If I press S, I want
to return a value of minus one. And if I press A,
I want to return a value of minus one, if I press
do moderate on the value plus one, why? Because
take a look at the axis. If you go forward,
it's usually positive. If I go backward, it's
negative. So to my movement input, I'm basically
going to say add one, two, as long as I'm pressing
my W button, add one to my movement input.
And if I press a it's going to add a value of
let's say minus one at that particular direction.
So why is it Why is a minus one, well take a look
at the x axis. If you look at the x axis, the left
part is minus one, the right part is supposed to
one. So that's basically how the coordinate system
works over here. Turn rate, what we're going to
do over here is I'm actually going to delete our
turn, rate and turn and our lookup rate over here.
And what we're going to do is, instead of this,
we're going to call this look tight, and then
we'll call this look up, look up is your mouse by
direction, it returns a value ranging
from minus one and four look right,
if I move my mouse in my x direction, it returns
a value ranging from bots to one, let's actually
see what that does. Now, in my input action,
if I press this, I want to print I am jumping.
So I can just say control me Compile, Save that
go back, I can remove this now, and all failed.
If I press space, it says I have
sheltered and if I release this,
if I go to my release part over here, I it's
only going to print this out when I release
my important. Okay, now, let's try to bind all
of Les I ran in said add some functionality.
If I right click and then search for mouse X,
make sure you get the event the the events and
not the mouse values. So I'm going to get mouse
X and mouse vi the events. So let's actually
see what I mean by when I say it returns a value
ranging from minus one. So what I'm what I can do
is from this node, I can print a string. And this
is a float, the green part is for float, what this
is doing is it's giving an output of or returning
a value of a float, which is the axis value. And
if I drag this end, it's going to convert a float
to a string. If I compile and save, go back,
Alt P, if I move my mouse, left and
right, actually, that was more sex,
yes, so that's going to be left and right, you can
see my values are ranging from one to minus one.
I mean, that starts from one, if I go right,
it's going to be positive, it's going to go if I
go left, it's going to be negative, it just keeps
adding that value over here. And the same goes you
can try this out for more spy, I'm not gonna waste
everybody's time trying to do the same thing for
most pilots will do the same thing. Okay, so let's
actually try to add our mouse movement over here.
If I go to my spring arm, I have to make sure
it always has used pawn control rotation. why?
It's because when I change when I what I'm going
to do is I'm going to change the control rotation
of the phone. And that's how I'm going to change
the rotation of the spring arm which changes the
rotation of the camera. Why? Because the camera
is the child of a spring arm. What that means is
that if I move my spring on the camera is going
to change with it just like how a kid follows
his or her mom all the time. That's basically how
the spring in the painting part works over here.
Same way the arrow is a child of the capsule
component the mesh is the child of capsule,
etc. which means as a moment capsule
permanent the mesh moves with it. Okay, so
we're going to change something called the yaw
and pitch, the pitch is the y axis the yaw is the
Zed axis. So with this axis value basically add
that value to the Y or the Zed axis. Let's see
how to do that. That's dragonoid. And we're
going to search for it. If it's the x axis,
we're going to add the your to it. Why? Because
the x axis, if I'm going to rotate with respect to
my x axis over here, that means I'll be rotating
it, you know, sideways, I don't want that, right.
So I'm basically rotated with respect
to the set axes, which is basically
left and right. So I can plug in this value over
here, copy, I mean, I'm not gonna copy that,
I'm just going to do the same thing, but for the
pitch over here, so add controller pitch input.
Now, keep in mind, if I have this disabled, so
all 10 like that, if I don't have an exit node
connected, it means this, this function will not
get executed, what is the function of function
is a chunk of code, which may or may not take an
input, and it provides an output based on that by
processing it. So you have an input, it processes
that input, calculates that does something and
then provides an output the output here being the
camera, getting the camera rotating on the scene.
So if I go back, Alt P, you can now see that
I have proper camera movement over here.
Now, if your axis is inverted, like for example,
if I go up, I want to go down. And if I move down,
I want to go up, if I want to do that, all I
have to do is go to my project settings again,
go to my input part, and I can just change
my mouse vide positive one. And if I alt v,
now, if I move, if I move up, I mean,
it just does the opposite, essentially.
Okay. Let's open up the blueprints, again, where
we we did this for our mouse, but we need to add
movement, obviously, to it. So let's do that. Now
let's get on events. So our move forward event was
basically binded to the keys W and a I mean,
W and S. So let's search for the access event
over here. And let's do the same for move right,
the X event. So I have the x value over here,
for move forward, I'm going to add this axis
value to something called the forward vector
of the character, the forward vector is basically
a vector that defines the forward direction. And
here we're going to add this to the right vector.
The right vector is essentially the the vector
that defines the right direction. So if I right
click and add movement, or if I search for this,
I need the world direction over here. The
whole direction is that basically we get actor.
Let's actually get the rotation over
here. So if I drag this over here,
get rotation, okay, get location, get
forward vector. So this is going to get
this direction is going to be the forward vector,
because we're going to, we're either going to move
forward or back. And this takes an input
asset rotation. Now, this is a variable,
the forward vector is a variable. And it's if
I mean, there's a function, the forward vector
itself is available, this get forward vector is
a function. And this does not have an exec mode,
which means it's a pure function, it returns a
vector, and I can add that to the world direction,
the scalar value is going to be the intensity,
which basically whether if I press W, it's going
to return a positive value, the press S, it's
going to return a negative value. And N rot
is basically the rotation, I'm going to get actor
rotation here. And so basically, what it's doing
is basically doing some complex math, and then
saying, Okay, I know what the forward vector is.
So move, depending on that direction. Now, the
same thing over here, and movement and foot,
but there's going to be for the right vector. So
get right vector. And we're again going to use the
actor's rotation over here. So that's that for our
movement. And that's pretty much it. We're done
with movement. So if at all fee now, I can move
left, right, forward, back, etc. And it works
perfectly fine. But my character is still in this
V pose, or this T pose. The reason this because
I don't have any animations assigned. Before
that, let's actually see how to make this neat.
Now, okay, the length of this node or this length,
the length of this line does not matter. It's not
it's not going to affect the speed at all. Just
just adding that I was dumb enough to believe
the speed was affected. Because of it. Don't be
like me, it's not. But always make sure it's neat.
Make sure you can see which line which axis, I
mean, which way was getting connected to what etc.
That is very important. So Compile and Save. Now
let's start, let's send a document our code over
here. If I select all of this, and press C, I can
add something called a comment. This does nothing
but it's just for us for our understanding. So I'm
just going to say add Movement Input over here,
and over here on the screen to see add mouse
input here. Now, we're not going to have,
we're not going to make a character jump, but
in case you want to add the functionality,
I'll show you how to do that. If I right click
and search for the jump event. So remember,
we have an action action event called
Jump. Very impressed this I want to start,
I want to just jump and jump is a built
in function of this character class.
So the character automatically starts jumping.
And over here, I can say Stop jumping, because
I don't want to keep going higher and higher and
higher. So all three, I have my jumping over here
to person. But I'm not going to bother adding this
because I don't want this in my game. But yes,
that is that for movement. Now that they've added
movement, the next part is to add animations. A
lot of people don't like animations. I personally
don't like adding animations. But unfortunately,
it is a part of game development. So let's
dive in on how to do that. For animations,
I have a different blueprint that I can add. So
I'm going to make content part and new folder.
I'm going to call this animations. And let's
create something called an animation blueprint.
Now the reason why we using an anime Animation
Blueprint, not the normal blueprint is because
the Animation Blueprint is optimized specially for
for blueprints and before animations, and it has
a lot of different functions built in. Now,
to create an animation blueprint, I have to
attach this or assign a skeleton to what we've
already seen what a skeleton is. So different
animations are made for different skeletons.
So make sure we select the YUI for manikin,
which is the built in skeleton, press OK,
the naming convention is AVP. Oops, again,
right click Rename a BP underscore, I'm just going
to name this battery man over here. Double click.
And now I have my output pose, I have two
different graphs. So here I have something
called the Adam graph, which basically decides
the output post and in the event graph, I can,
let's say get the speed of the character and then
change the animations based on that. That's what
these two graphs to the Event Graph is for
all the functionality like um, getting the
variables adding values to the variables,
etc. The enum graph is to decide the output
pose. If I drag a node from here, and search for
the run animation plate or person run and compile.
Now, this over here takes an input if your if your
variable is on the left side, it means it's taking
an input. If it on the right side, it means the
node is giving an output. So the third person
is going to get the animation, use the animation
pose as an output. And that output is sent as an
input to this output. So here, component save,
I had to go to Batman and assign my animation
blueprint. So I can either select my animation
blueprint and then hit this arrow over here.
Or I can just search by a BP underscore
batch command. Now Compile and Save.
If I run this now, you can see that my animation
is getting played continuously. I don't want that
I want that idle animations, all of that.
I want a different animation for strafing,
it just looks really weird. So we're going to
create something called a blend space for that.
Let's take a look at what blend spaces. So good
animation. And so it's for blend space. And again,
you have to assign the skeleton. So
this will be BS underscore battery man.
Okay, now, let's open this up. And this might
look a little confusing, but essentially,
the Blendspace has the x axis and the Y axis.
And depending on the values of this, also a
certain animation will be played. For example,
let's take a look at the vertical and the
horizontal the vertical. I think
the vertical is this one over here.
Yeah, that's the speed. So that's vertical
axis, we're going to name this the speed
and in the bottom on the horizontal axis the
direction. So based on my direction and my speed,
I can play a particular animation. So my
minimum speed over here is going to be zero,
my maximum axis value over here, my maximum three,
the 600. As we set in our movement component,
a minimum axis value here is going to be 180.
by Paul maximum is going to be first a 180. So
Y, first 180. And next 181 80 is usually forward,
negative 180 is the complete opposite direction.
So that's what we're doing over here.
Okay, so basically, what I'm saying is,
actually, let's do this with an example search
under this Asset Browser source for your idle
animation, and drag and drop this at the bottom.
What I'm saying here is, if my speed is zero,
regardless of my direction, make sure you
play the idle animation, I'm pretty sure
you can now understand what this is doing. So
if my speed is zero, then I'm going to play
my idle animation. Now you may understand where
to put your run animation, it's going to be all
the way at the top. Now, if you hold Shift, and
actually sort of move around, you can actually
you can preview the animation. So if my speed is
set, if my direction is at zero, which is forward,
and my speed is at 600, then I'm going to
play that animation. And it's slowly trances
rate slowly adds the value. So my animation
slows down as I go down. And my preview value,
if my speed is at zero, regardless of my
direction, I'm still going to stay idle.
So that's what it does. If my direction is at
90, I want I want to make sure I move left. So
let's search for that search going on, experts
take a look at all families over here. Okay, so
they would usually happens is we have different
animations for when the character turns left, and
when the character on site. But the animation, the
animations that come built in, we unfortunately
don't have those animations. So what we're going
to do is we're just going to add run over here.
And remember, when my direction is at, usually,
you'll have also a backward run animation.
So when the direction is at minus money at MIT,
you usually want your the want to move backwards,
so you have different animation for that,
and you will add that, respectively.
So that's just add this animation,
I really don't want to do this. But
in our C++ course, I'll make sure we get
animations for moving right moving left,
actually, let's try deleting the all the other
values, let's just have one for moving forward.
If I save this, and all be okay, obviously, I need
to assign this Blendspace in the animation token,
because we still haven't assigned it yet. So if
I go to my animation blueprint, I can drag a node
and search for Blendspace. So now I can see my
Blendspace vs underscore Batman. And this takes
in two inputs, one is going to be the direction
one is going to be the speed and based on that it
will choose an animation, which is what we set. So
from here, I'm going to drag and load and promote
this to a variable. So it automatically creates
a variable called direction and it's a float. And
I'm going to promote this to a variable and it's
going to be speed, compile, go to my event graph.
Now in my event graph, I can get the speed and the
direction. So let's see how to do that. Now from
tie get pawn owner, what this does is it tries
to get the owner of this animation blueprint.
So I can now cast this to my BP battery man, why
am I doing this, but that's actually that's mainly
because I have my point upon is the class but
I have to convert my class to my battery man.
The way this works is if I go to my BP underscore
battery man and add a variable, I'm just going to
call this test variable. And I want to get hold
of this variable. I can't get this from porn,
I can just say get test variable, it does
not exist. But if I convert this to a Batman,
and then as Batman, if I try get test variable,
now I can get hold of the very variable. So we're
trying to just localize our localized this pawn
to my VPN scope actually, man. So from here, we're
going to actually first what we're gonna do is
we're going to check to see if we got our foreign
owner or not, and that is done using the S valid
node. So if I Get my point honor, if if I'm not
able to get my point or I can just say, I can just
print a string saying I porn on are not valid.
Now the reason why we're doing this is because of
attorney get a few variables from the point honor
the to make sure we have that pawn owner, if not
your game is and up your game is going to crash
to this the safer way of doing it. If it is valid,
what we're going to do is we're going to cast to
third cast to PP underscore Batman. And this has
an exec node. So obviously this goes to as valid.
As Batman, what I'm going to do is we're going
to get a variable called get velocity. So
the velocity is obviously the speed. But remember,
velocity has direction, and magnitude. So from get
velocity, we're going to get, we're going to
calculate that you're going to get the that
we're going to get the vector length,
the return value is going to be your speed. So we
already we already promoted this to a variable.
So we're going to set this variable here. So drag
this variable onto your event graph and press Alt,
and then you can just drag the return value
on to speed which means now the value of the
speed is going to be the velocity, the vector
of velocity from battery man, we'd obviously
set the direction to we're not done yet. So
from here, we're going to get actor rotation.
And from the rotation, we are going to calculate
direction. So obvious for the direction you need
to calculate what you need calculate the velocity.
So from the velocity, you get something called the
direction to that's how vectors work. And again,
I'm going to the same direction. And I can set
the value. After setting speed, I'm going to set
the direction. So the control flow is basically
update animation. This is basically going
to happen every single frame. From here,
it's going to go to S valid, it's going to check
if the pawn owners valid, if it is cost to pvns,
go battery man. So convert porn to Batman,
from here, get the velocity Get Actor rotation,
calculate the vector length,
calculate the direction, set the speed
and then set the direction, we can
actually then keep this over here.
Now we have the values for speed and direction,
all you have to do is go to Anam graph,
and you can see that it has already set the
direction and the speed. So now Compile and Save,
go back. And if you press ALT T, I now have my
animations. Obviously, it does look a little
weird that if I go left and right, I don't have
proper animations. But that's actually going to be
actually try to do this on your own search
for your left and right animations. Go to your
go to this namespace. When your direction is at
minus Canadian 180, you want to make sure the
character goes backwards. And for left and right
animations here, you're going to place your right
animation here, you're going to press your left
animation and check if it works. And if it does,
then you understood how blend spaces work. But
we're gonna move on the game. As you've seen at
the beginning, the way the game works is you have
a lot of different batteries all around the map.
And the health of the player keeps decreasing.
And you have to make sure you collect all of
these batteries. And if you do, then you
go to the next level or you win the game.
So let's see how to do that. This is where
we'll be learning about UI, etc. So that's
going to be there's going to be the second part
of the course. If I go to my blueprints, method
person actually not method freschetta. Obviously,
it has to be my AVP underscore Batman, I mean, my
btn school Batman over here, we're going to create
a new variable called Health. Let's remove this.
And let's create a health variable. Over
here, I'm going to search for now I'm
going to make this a float and compile
the default value as the default value.
And what's going on with me the default value
is going to be 100. Compile and Save. Now,
what we're going to do is we're going to get
our event tech and every five seconds we are
going to reduce the health. How do I do that
dragon node and then add a delay over here.
What this does is it's basically going to wait for
X amount, they're going to wait every five seconds
and get this value. So if you Jacqueline's
funny on the screen and then hit Ctrl,
and then place it you will get, you'll be
able to get whatever value your health is.
And we're going to subtract. So if I just be, as
you can see, if I search for minus, I can subtract
a value, and I'm going to subtract a value of mine
of five maybe. So once I've subtracted the value,
so let's say my health is 100. If I subtract it,
the output is going to be 95. And I have set over
here, again, set whatever value I've returned.
And then once I'm done, I can just do that.
Now, basically, every five seconds, I'm going
to reduce my health, let's print my health out.
Actually, for simplicity, I mean, just make
sure it's faster, I'm going to make it every
two seconds, and drag and drop health, again,
converted into a string and plugged into my friend
strength file and save it. Now you can see it's
100, after two seconds, 95. And then it's 9085,
etc. So it keeps going down. What I'm
going to do is, I am going to add some UI,
I'm going to add a health bar so that this
is connected to that, I'm going to reduce
my health every two seconds, but I'm going
to reduce my health by 10, Compile and Save.
Now, I have to do something called binding, I'm
going to bind this house to my UI. So let's take
a look at how to create UI. Under blueprints, I'm
going to create a new folder and call this UI.
And under UI, you can go to FX, I actually
not effects. This is not a user interface.
And I'm going to create a Widget Blueprint,
the naming conventions W BP underscore whatever
name I'm going to call this player UI. So in
this, we have something called the designer
and the designer, this what the UI is
going to look like you can design me,
you can basically place all of these objects, and
you can make it look like a proper UI, we're going
to add something called a progress bar over here.
Let's actually scale this about let me make this
500. And I'm going to do something called
anchoring. What this means is as I resize my
screen, so for example, if I minimize my screen,
I want my, I want this to still stay at the top
left corner. And if I make it fullscreen, it
should move along with the screen. That's what
anchoring means. So I'm going to
make sure that it's over there.
And if I scroll all the way down, under style,
I have something called the Fill image. If I,
if I'm, if I drop this down, I have something
called the 10th. The first image is going to be
the actual health over here. So I'm
going to make sure my I mean my battery,
my battery is going to be green, that actually
reminds me how to change this to battery not here.
Okay, and make sure you save that here and
compile. And over here, our background image,
let's just make this actually let's make
that black, that's fine. And we have to we
have something called the percent. Now the person
ranges from zero to one, if it's one is going to
be completely filled. If it's zero, it's going to
be empty. Let's make the default full. And we're
going to do something called binding it. So you
see this bind button, and you can select Create
Binding. And what we're what we're going to do
is we're going to get the health and we're going
to set that health to this percentage, we're
going to convert the health into percentage,
and then we're going to set it over here. So
the return value is going to be the percentage
that's displayed. So now we can say Get Player
Character. And that's going to return whatever
character I've possessed the good RBC convert
this to my Batman. So once we've done that,
as Batman, we can just get our health and get
battery. And then we can set that over here.
But remember, we have to convert this into
percentage because this person is going to be
between zero and one. So what we're gonna do is
we're going to divide this by 100. Remember by
by definition percent means per cent cent is 100.
So, we're going to divide this by 100. And then
Return it over here, Compile and Save. Now, we
have to add this UI on to the screen. To do that,
let's go to bed, let's have our begin play, all
the UI will be instantiated in being in play.
Over here, we're going to create a widget. So
we're going to create an object of this player
UI. So I need to select which class, that's
going to be my WP player UI. And return value,
I'm going to add this to Viewport. So
it's basically to add this player UI on
the viewport and whatever function binding, it's
going to make sure it executes all of that code.
So now if I play, you can see that my percent
bar is slowly decreasing, which is amazing.
And it has some amazing decal, too. So it has
some animated graphics. So that's very cool.
As well, um, Unreal Engine, it does everything
for you. And we can now remove this frame string.
Now, again, we have to make sure it only reduces
the value until it costs zero. And once it goes to
zero, I want to kill my player. So to do that,
first off, we're going to decrease the value
only if my battery is more than zero. So if
I drag control, we now can search for the
greater than symbol. And if it's greater than
zero, only then execute this. But how do we do
that? How do we add conditions, we do that by
something called a branch. So you can see that
red color over here. So if it's more than zero,
it's going to return true. If it's less than zero,
it's going to return false. So from here, I can
create something called a branch. And I can now
add this to this branch. Now, if my health is
more than zero, then I'm going to execute this.
So I'm going to move that to the top. If my
health is less than zero, then I'm going to say
my player is dead. So that time I'm going to add
a retry screen etc. And I'm going to make sure I
do not possess this character anymore. But we will
see that later on. But let's create a variable.
Now. Let's say B is player that's a naming
convention for bool boolean values, you make sure
it's B is clear that or whatever. And we're going
to make sure this Boolean compile, and the default
value is going to be false. And if I hold Alt and
drag this onto the scene, we can set this to be
true over here. Awesome. Now, if player is dead,
then obviously, I've lost so I'll use a pull out
menu screen menu. And I can either retry the game,
or I can play the game again. So that is the basic
functionality that we're going to use over here.
Once the player is said, what we're going to do is
we are going to we have this function called
detach from controller pending destroy. What this
does is it makes sure your controls don't affect
the player once you have detached from once you're
dead. So if I wait and wait for it's actually
let's let's make that faster, have no patience,
I'm going to make that 20 so that as soon as I
spawn in like four seconds, I end up dying. So
that's there. And now you can see that you can
try controlling, but you will notice that your
controls don't work. And that's because we have
detached from this controller. And we need the
animation to stop playing. So we can we can
also have another so we can we can either
stop our animation like this, but this might not
work. Let's try that out. Let me make that funny
because I don't want to wait four seconds, Compile
and Save. All pay. Now the animations are still
playing. So we have to take care of this through
the Adam montage. I mean the animation blueprint,
we have this variable here is player dead.
So we're going to get this variable from our
BP battery man. And if it's true, they're going
to stop animation. So let's see how to do that.
We'll be learning about a new thing called the
blend by blue. Yeah, the Blendspace by blue.
Okay. Over here in this enum enum graph we've seen
before that we have something called a branch. So
if the condition is true, do this condition is
false to that. Instead, what we'll do is we'll
say, just search for both answers blends poses by
bool. then post this by blue. Okay, anyways, if
so we can pass in a bool value over here. And
if it's true, it will do this. If it's false,
we'll do something else. Now, if a player is not
dead, we want this Blendspace. If the player is
there, then we can just, maybe I know, we can
play the idle animation over here. And how do
we get this value? Same way, we have BP battery
man, they can also say get the S is player that
and we can promote this to a variable. So promote
the variable and bring this all the way to the top
and compile. Now I think
you can understand the rest,
we can just drag and drop this over here. And
now it's going to make sure if there's dead
then just want to play the idle animation and not
do anything because we don't have fuel to run.
There we go. That works perfectly fine. And
after this, we have to make sure we display
our player Lua screen. Now try to do this on
your own, it might be a little difficult, but
just give it a shot. If you can't, no
problems we're going to do anyways,
we're going to create a new user interface, we're
actually going to create two of them. One is for
player when one is for player two is. So we WP
underscore. Actually, we don't need a blueprint
of Widget Blueprint for when because we're
automatically just going to go to the next level.
Or we're just going to have it is going to
go to the next level. And here we can just
name this the BV WPP Lu screen and the designer
part. I'm going to add an image first, let's scale
this completely, so it fits this handle. And make
sure we have this properly aligned. Okay anyways,
even if it's oversized no problems, we're going
to anchor this to be full screen. There we go.
So it's going to be it's going to make sure it's
always full screen. And I'm going to change the
opacity to I'm gonna change the color to black
and the F two like that. That looks fine. We're
going to have two buttons now. The first button
is basically going to be one sec. Give me a second
Okay, the first button what it's going to
do is when there's when the the retry part,
so retry game, and need to add some text
to it. The same button, I can do the cater.
And they're going to add this over
here. I know it's not exactly aligned,
but that's fine. This is going to be quit aim want
to quit color and opacity seems just fine for me.
Yeah, that's that seems just fine. No problems.
Okay, now let's see how to add text to this,
all you have to do is search for text and drag
and drop it, it's going to automatically pair it
make this a child. And either the text block over
here are going to save the try game. Or actually
usually just as we try. And on the phone,
I'm going to change the size to maybe 34.
That seems fine. And for quick game again,
another text block, they're going to make it 3042.
And we can just say quit. Game nation, I'm
gonna name this text block to quit text.
And this one is going to be retry. And we're
going to have a huge block of text over here.
And this one, we're going to name it. We're
just going to say you do is that's that's pretty
much it. Let me make that 80 actually living and
textbook I'm just saying I'm just going to say you
Louis. Okay, awesome. In my graph, I have to make
sure I add functionality to this to these buttons.
So if you scroll all the way to the bottom after
you've selected the button we have on click and on
press, we're going to use the on pressed because
it works better for example, if you press enter
by mistake it might just end up retrying again,
we don't want that we have to make sure we click
on the button. So that's why we use on pressed do
the same for retry game to I mean for quit game.
Not on flick on pressed over here. And for retry,
they're going to open We're going to load the
level, we're going to load the exact same level.
So that level is going to be get level get current
level name. Because if it's a different level, if
it's level two, then it has to make sure it has,
it opens up that level. So get current name
ensures it gets the proper level, the level
that you're running right now. And we're going
to open that level. So it's basically to open
the same level, again, all the default settings
for quit game, it's literally just one node,
quit game. That is it, Compile and Save.
Now if I minimize my screen called P, again,
we have to make sure we add it to Viewport.
So if I go to my blueprints, if my player is
that detached from controller pending, destroyed,
that's fine. And whatever we did here, we're doing
the exact same thing over here. But the problem
is, remember, this is on tick. And when we create,
when we put this on tick, it means it's going
to create the player widget every single frame
and add it to Viewport every single frame, which
means your game might end up crashing. So we're
going to add a note that says do once. This means
that it's going to whatever that comes after it's
going to do this only once. They're going to burn
to make sure we recreate the loo screen widget,
and then we're going to Add to Viewport. Now
if we compile and save it, let's run the game.
And now it says he lose. But the
problem is we cannot use our mouse,
we can only you know we have to press windows
etc. So if you want to show the mouse cursor,
get your Player Controller anything related to
controls that's present in the Player Controller,
and over here, search for cursor.
Let's see what we have over here.
We have get Show Mouse Cursor Set Show Mouse
Cursor. So we can set this by this value is
present in the Player Controller, we can set this
to true after Compile and Save this and minimize.
And we're running around. And now I can see my
cursor. If I press retry. It loads the same level
again, and I'm losing and blah, blah,
blah. So it basically restarts the level.
Okay, awesome. We've done all of that. Now
let's see how to convert these into functions.
Functions are basically blocks of
code made into one chunk of an object,
which you can call later on. For example, if I
right click on all of this collapse to function,
collapsing the function fail, let's see why
is that okay? Delay cannot be okay, some.
Okay, let's just create a test function over
here, test function. So this function can have
a lot of different functionality. For example,
imagine I have 1000 nodes in this graph over here,
forgot to even graph if I'm, if I
want to call this function again,
like in 10 different positions. What if it makes
better sense for me to call this function rather
than creating those 1000 nodes again, and again,
and again, that's going to look very, very dirty,
which is why I'd rather put those 1000 function
those 1000 nodes in one function, and then I can
call this function, and delays cannot be added
in a function. So if I right click over here,
I can just collapse this to a function. And I
can say that use health. And this function we
know that reduces health. If I double click on
this, it does the exact same thing over here.
Now, if you want you can convert this
to a function to I'm going to leave it
they've done that for now they've made functions
for me, we've made a function for it yourself,
but I'm going to leave the player death part as it
is. But I can maybe add this part to a function.
But that depends on you. Or I can just collapse
this to a node to collapse to node player deck.
So this basically just instill in an 11th
graph. It's not it's not a function or anything,
but we're just making this part of the
code faster. I mean, shorter so that we can
find out what's going on. Okay, so now let's
create a variable called battery's collected,
there should be an integer by, what we're going
to do is we're going to have a maximum number of
batteries per level. For example, this level will
probably have eight different band aid batteries.
And once we've collected all batteries, we're
going to check if the number of batteries
we've collected is equal to the number of
patties that are supposed to be collected.
And if it is equal, then we can say the player
has won the game and move to the next level.
Or they can just display when screen but in this
case We're going to just move to a new level,
and you can add all the other functionalities.
So once we've reduced health, this part means the
player has not died yet, as you can see over here.
So what we'll do is, after releasing the head,
we're gonna check to see if the number of
batteries we've collected is equal. But actually,
we're not going to do this in the player, we're
going to do this in something called the Level
Blueprint. So if I go to my level effects here on
blueprint, and if I hit on Open Level Blueprint,
this is a different type of blueprint, it is for
the level itself, and it can get access to every
single object that's present in the level. And I
can add functionality based on that, for example I
can get, I can get the character that's present
in this level, and then check to see how many
back he has collected. And and check to see if the
number of batteries I've collected is, you know,
equal to the number of get batteries
they're supposed to be collected,
and then change to the next level. So that started
with that. First off, in begin play, we're going
to get hold of our BP underscore Batman. So
Get Player Character, we're gonna cost it
to be fi underscore Batman. So we're gonna, we're
going to convert our character to the Batman.
And then as Batman, we're going to promote this
to a variable, so that we have a reference to our
player at all times. And in tech. So now we'll
be introducing something else. But before we
we start making our Venn conditions, let's
actually implement our batteries themselves.
So right click, create a new blueprint. And this
is going to be an actor, TV underscore battery.
If I open this up, I'm going to add something
called box. And I'm just going to add, actually,
let me just add a cube over here. If I scroll all
the way to the bottom, okay, I'm adding a cube,
this is going to be my battery, your title, try to
try to change the Static Mesh to something else,
maybe try to find a battery acid
and change the mesh to a battery.
But I'm going to leave this as it is, we're going
to scale it. So if you want to scale and press our
I'm going to make this flat. Something like that.
Okay, awesome. Now, what we'll have to do is,
let me change the material to maybe I've seen this
really cool material that Unreal Engine has, it
has this very cyberpunk like texture, there we go.
I love this texture. I'm going to make it this.
Okay. Now, if we scroll all the way to the bottom,
we have a lot of different events. What these
events are, is that when the component is hit,
do something, when that when someone overlaps
the component, do something when an object has
ended overlapping, do something. That's basically
all these events are. That's what these events
do, let's try to take a look at the on component
head event called when a component hits something
solid. So if this component hits, maybe something
solid, like another cube or a player, what is it
supposed to do, that's how projectile bullets work
in game development to let's try to take a look
at on competent head, press on if I click on the
plus symbol, I have something called the head
component. And the other actor, the other actor
is going to be whatever actor that has collided or
hit this cube over here. And we're going to cost
this to our battery man. No, not the battery,
the battery man. So search for battery man.
Now if this is true, so if I have
cost, if I have hit the battery man,
then we're going to get the health. Get
the battery. And then we're going to add,
maybe let's see, we're going to add an amount
that actually let's make this a random value,
subtract a node from this and then there
should be there should be a node that says
random float in range, we're going to we're
going to add a value between five and 10. So
there's going to return a value of five and have
a number, a random number between five and 10.
And from battery we're going to set
battery again. And then we can drag this in
for Compile and Save. Let's see if this works. And
I have to obviously destroy this object because
I don't want to cheat so I can destroy the actor
which means it's going to get deleted from the
scene. If I placed this object over here, and
move this to the top, maybe we can add some lines
This what? Oops, okay, I have to make sure
I, the game isn't that difficult for me.
So I'm going to change my battery value
back to 100, Compile and Save old faith,
fam move towards this battery, you can
see that my head has increased over here,
let me show you again my battery. So you can see
it's slowly increased, which is what we're going
to do over here. Now, we're going to make sure we
keep increasing our battery for our player over
here. Let me go back to my BP underscore battery,
let me add a light over here, point light. And
make sure you raise it to the top because if it's
inside the object, you won't be able to see it.
And we can make it red in color. Okay, Compile
and Save. Now, here comes the interesting part.
This is where we make our wind conditions. So
over here, once we've added health added, okay,
my opponent has been added battery to our battery
man, we can add a variable to the batteries
the player has collected. So again,
get the batteries collected over here.
And we obviously have the set of doses set that is
collected, I hope this doesn't get too confusing.
If you do, then try to make try to do a little bit
of math in a in a different project on your own by
getting values from a player and casting them. And
you will be able to understand them in no time,
I'm going to add one to the number of
batteries collected. So if I let's say I
have three batteries already collected, I'm going
to add one to it. So that's going to become four,
I'm going to set the batteries collected.
And then I'm going to destroy the cube,
Compile and Save. Now in my Level Blueprint, I
have to make sure I define what is the maximum
number of batteries, right. So let's try to do
that. Now, right like, we're going to take a
look at something called the Game Instance. So
let's take a look at Game Instance over here.
Now gi underscore battery, man
instance citizen all of that.
So in this instance, what a Game Instance is that
it is an object that persists persists through
every single level. So this object will be there
in the main level. And then level one, level two,
level three, this this is going to persist in
every single level. So we can add a few variables
that says okay, if it is level one, then make sure
the number of batteries is let's say eight. And
that will do it has to be 10 etc. Now, this is
not the best way to do it. But since this is a
very beginner level tutorial, we're not going to
go over gameplay, like proper gameplay mechanics.
So I'm just going to add a variable here. So level
one, then batteries, actually no Max batteries.
One. So this indicates for level one, this is
the maximum number of batteries are going to
make it a float. And let's this let's set this
value to eight. Now, if you want another level,
let's say level two, you can say Max batteries,
two, etc. Now go to the Level Blueprint. And you
will have to do this for every single level. But
in tech, what we can do is we can right click
Get Game Instance, we have to cast this to our
battery man instance cost vi battery man instance.
And again, we can do this in big and
play because we don't want to talk we
don't want to cost this every single frame.
And then we can promote this to a variable
gi battery math. Okay, now from the battery
man instance, what we can do is we can get
max batteries for one. And then from our battery
man, the player itself, we can get get batteries
connected. We're going to check if these are
equal. Now I forgot to make this an integer.
So let's make sure this is an integer to Compile
and Save level one that's checked to see if these
are equal. So I can if these are equal, then I can
basically say so again, we have to create a branch
so we're creating a condition over here. So if
we create a branch Event Tick, if these two are
equal, then I've won the game. So I can just
end up opening the next level or again I can
I can have a windscreen or whatever match has been
opened another scene for this one. And let's call
this level, the next level, whatever. For example,
this one's going to be level two, you will have to
do this for every single game level. But remember
in the C++ course, since that's going to be a more
advanced course, we will take a look at how to
make this a lot more scalable in the sense how
to make sure we just add the logic once and
we don't have to keep copy pasting our code
on and on and on. Now that they've created the
Game Instance, we have to make sure we set it in
our project settings. So go to maps and modes. And
if you scroll all the way down, our default Game
Instance has to be gi underscore battery instance,
let us create another level over here. So again,
new level, there's going to be a default level
and save it. We're going to call this level two.
And that's pretty much it. I bet we're done
with all of our code mechanics. Now, if I play
the game, and let's say our maximum is going to be
one. So if I open up my Game Instance, over here,
my maximum number of entries is going to be one,
for example, save the game. And if I play now,
we now move to the next level. So that's how we
make our vent conditions. Now all you have to do
is decorate your level, maybe add a few obstacles,
and maybe like a few cubes that distracts the
player, maybe trying to make this into a maze,
get a few assets from the marketplace and try
to make it in such a way that maybe it's like in
a spaceship, and the player has to find all the
batteries from the spaceship, which would probably
look really cool. But now I have five different
batteries here. So I'm going to go to my Game
Instance, maximum batteries is going to be five
over here. Compile and Save, and save it. Okay.
Now let's see if this still works. So all fie
I'm going to collect, oops, it seems like I have
to make sure this is all the way to the bottom.
So all the way to the bottom, all the way
to the bottom. Okay, all fee. Now let's see.
So first, my battery does keep
increasing. So that's pretty cool. But
okay, I might, I might actually lose this. I'm not
really good at games. Okay. Okay, we seem to be we
seem to win the game. That's awesome. And yeah,
that's pretty much it for our vendor events. Now,
let's say your level two is your last event,
what you do is in your level two Level Blueprint.
So if you open up the blueprint, just have the
same condition that as you had in level one,
except if it's equal, you create a new
widget, your your windscreen, for example.
And then you display that windscreen on to the
scene. For example, if I go to level two, now,
let me actually show you how to do it real quick.
So if I go to level two, open my Level Blueprint,
now I can try to do this on your own, please
don't try to copy what I'm doing. That's fine,
I want to show everything because I want to
sort of make sure you guys get it on your own.
What you do is you will get your Game Instance
again, you will cost this two battery instance.
And we're pretty much doing the same thing we
did before. And remember, if you have level two,
your level two Level Blueprint open, you
can open your level one level blueprint,
it's going to get closed automatically. So
we're going to promote this to a variable.
And same thing. The same thing happens except
it's going to be for our Player Character. So Get
Player Character cost to battery man. So
basically converting it to battery man
and then promote the variable. And then we
can get max, I mean get batteries collected.
And we can use this to compare. So in our Event
deck, what we'll do is we can get these to
get batteries man so there's going to be so we
have to create a new condition for level two.
So all you have to do is Ctrl C Ctrl V, rename
this to max batteries to I'm just going to make
sure the max battery is just
something like one for my level two.
So this is equal to the number of batteries are
collected, not battery number of patties collected
batteries collected If this is true, what's
going to happen is I can just print out,
I can create a new widget, there's going
to be my winning windscreen over here,
which is going to basically have a text
that says you win the game, and then
it can have a quick game. And then over here,
we can say cost to, I mean, and to Viewport
for time to compile, that it has an arrow
here, because the Create Widget class has
to be specified. So let's create
a new UI element over here. So UI.
Actually, let me just let me let me do
skaters W, BP underscore wind screen.
Now in stuff lose, they can just say, you when.
And we're going to load out for
retry, we'll load the first level.
And actually, let's have the return to
main menu part in this vein main menu,
and quit game. Yeah, fifth game is going to be
the same. Now in the graph, open level four,
because we have to make sure we rename everything
because we just duplicated it. So for retry Game
Over here, we have to make sure this says main
menu now. It's just for simplicity's sake. Now
when you press the main menu, we want to open
up the main menu. So we're going to create a
new level called Main Menu, obviously, Compile
and Save. Because if I go to level two, I can
just create the main screen and make sure you get
the Player Controller. So Get Player Controller.
Show Mouse Cursor, we're going to set it
not get it. So Show Mouse Cursor set it
we are going to set this to true, Compile
and Save. Now we have the main menu
we have the main menu part. And that's
pretty much it. So my condition for
my second level is going to be two sets need
to collect two batteries and I've in the game.
So over here, we're going to end up adding
batteries again, we'll add two batteries.
If I played the game now collected one
collected two, and doesn't seem to be working,
let's take a look at what's going on. Okay,
the reason why I wasn't working was because
I got the variable for the first
level. So we're going to get batteries
over here and make sure we set that now it's
going to work. So if I Compile and Save,
and again, remember we have to make sure we detach
from so okay, if I go back to my battery man,
you see we have detached from pending destroy over
here, we're going to do the same thing over here.
That's because as I move my mouse, I don't want my
camera to move to in my windscreen. So let's see,
let's actually see if we can get this on our own.
So detach from nope, I'm not able to get that
get that particular node. So let's see if that's
present in our Player Controller. No, it's not
present in our Player Controller, which means
it should be present in our character itself.
detach from controller pending destroyed,
there we go. We can do that Compile and Save.
So this means we cannot control our player
anymore. So once I collect these two batteries,
it says you went and again one more problem.
This is going on in tech. So we have to make
sure we do this only once. We don't want this
every frame it's going to crash your game which
was about to crash my game. So we have to
make sure that only that's done only once.
If you want you can make put all of this in a
function. And yet we're gonna save this go back
OLOFI collect the first one second one, we went
quit game and we're done with the game. Awesome.
Now, obviously this is not the best way to make
a winning condition but if you want to do it,
don't worry about making it the best way possible
the first time you're trying it. The main the
main point is to understand how blueprints work
first, and then in the next course that is fine.
The next course is going to be a more advanced
course where we learn Proper winning conditions,
all gameplay principles, etc. Now, we have one
more thing remaining. And then we're finally
done with this course, which is going to be our
main menu. So, in fact, I had to create another
Widget Blueprint, W BP underscore main menu
over here. And I'm going to add an image again.
Let's make this fullscreen and anchored,
make sure that's fullscreen. And now,
what we're going to do is, well, let me change
this to black first, this is going to have two
buttons, one is going to be play game one is
going to be quit game. That's pretty much it.
And I'm pretty sure this is self explanatory.
I'm pretty sure most of you guys will be able
to do this on your own by now. But if
not, no problems, don't feel demotivated,
it's completely fine. It's normal. So
we're gonna save play game over here.
Duplicate this control, actually, yeah,
Ctrl W, that's duplicate. And they go,
they're going to make this, I'm going to call this
quit game. And obviously, you can have another,
you can have another button that shows the
controls, etc. Over here, that's add some text,
text to both play game and do it again, I
added it to the image by mistake. So I'm
going to remove that there's going to be called
play game. This is going to be called load game.
And obviously, we want to change
the size to like maybe 34.
That's not gonna be faking. I'm just gonna quickly
over here. And over here, again, go back to the
font, make this 34 Compile and Save. How do we
tell the editor that whenever we open up a project
or the game, we need to make sure it opens this
main menu level. To do that go to maps and modes.
And you can see your editor startup map and
your game default map, what I'm going to do
is I'm going to create a new level and
make sure it opens up the main menu over
there. Now open up a new level. Actually,
we don't need to make it a default level,
we can just create an empty level over here. And
Ctrl S, you can see that it's completely dark
because there's nothing in this level, we're
going to call this the Main Menu. Over here,
what we're going to do is open up your Level
Blueprint. Before that we had to add a game
mode override because as I said, it doesn't have
to add. So if I run this game now, it's going to
Okay, all up. If you see it spawns up, it spawns
the BP underscore Batchi. Man, we don't want that,
obviously. So what we're going to do is we're
going to add a game mode override over here,
which means for this level alone, it's going
to create a different game mode and it's going
to use that so under Custom custom blueprints,
I'm going to create GM underscore main menu.
And over here, under default
point, it's going to be none
under hard, I'm just going to have all
of this normal. Now. Under blueprints
Open Level Blueprint, again, we're going to do
the same except this might be in vegan play.
So Create Widget. And what we're going to
create is the main menu and Add to Viewport
Compile and Save. Now if I go back to my project
settings, scroll over scroll down here I have my
editor start up map. I'm going to keep my level
selected over here so content levels main menu,
I am going to hit this arrow and it's going to
automatically assign my main menu now let's play
the game. So press Play Game nothing happens
that is because we haven't added functionality
yet. So if I go to main menu, select
this button again scroll all the way to
the bottom on pressed you know what to do
open level this is going to be level one.
And if if I go to quit game on pressed again,
you can just quit the game. Now make sure
in level two level blue in our windscreen Level
Blueprint. It the level is named properly. So
that's main menu without a space, Compile and
Save. And this is to have a sense playthrough now.
So if I alt V three game, I have my HUD, and you
may have VLC because of that, okay, there we go.
We're going to try to
collect all of these on time.
And that's level two. And level two, we're going
to, we're going to get these two. And now we win
the game. And we can quit the game. That is pretty
much it. Now we have a tiny little part over here,
the animation keeps playing for
the animation keeps playing for our
well in our level two after we win the game,
because we haven't added a win condition
in our Animation Blueprint. So what we're going
to do is we're also going to add another variable,
and this variable is going to be called B has
layer one. Now in begin play, I'm going to make
sure I set this value to false and make sure this
is a bool. So we're gonna change variable type.
Close Compile and Save, and
make sure we set this to false
every single time we start playing the game.
Over here, in my Level Blueprint, again, what
I'm going to do is in level one, at Save Selected
blueprints, Open Level Blueprint. And we
have to make sure we get this character
from the from the character over here, set.
Clear one has player one over here. If it's true,
then we can set we can actually we have to set
this only in level two, not our level one, because
our player hasn't technically won the entire
game completely yet. So if I go to level two,
open up my Level Blueprint, I have the same
thing over here too. Now if I, if I from the
battery man, I have to set one just search for has
player one, I'm going to double click on this node
so that I can redirect this node over here
like that. Move it all the way to the end.
And then connect this, we're going to set
this to true, I'm going to again add another
node over here so we can detect it
properly said looks a little neat.
Compile and Save. Now let's open up our our
Animation Blueprint. And open that up. Okay,
over here now we're blending spaces wherever
blending poses by bool over here. Now, if player
is dead, they're going to play the idle animation.
But if the player is dead, or if the player
has won the game, we're still
going to play the idle animation.
So over here, we're going to have an all Boolean,
what this does is it checks if one of these will
so takes into bool values. And if it cannot
be stick a lot more can take five, six, etc.
But we just need to have these. So
we're going to remove, then remove pan
over here if the player is dead, or if the
player has one, plate, the player dead animation.
So to get that cost to Batman, we've already done
that. From here, we will get one has clear one.
Move this all the way to the bottom. And
again, we're going to promote this to
available the name is fine. And all the way to
the end. There we go. That looks a little neat.
AnimGraph place this over here. So if any one of
these conditions are true, we're going to play
the idle animation. So if I now play the
second level one to see now my animations
don't play continuously. So I can now quit
the game. And that works perfectly fine.
Awesome. Now that is pretty much it for this
game. Your challenge is to add your own map
try to add your own level, go to the marketplace
get there a lot of free assets that you can use.
Maybe make this into a spaceship and try this
out. The only problem now is that unfortunately
since Unreal Engine five is still under
development, most of the assets are not compatible
with the engine. So if I go back to my Epic Games
launcher and if I try to add this free asset that
I got from the free for the month thingie if
I click on show all projects and try to select
Unreal Engine five You can see it says asset
is not compatible. So what you'd have to do is
you'd have to downgrade this project to Unreal
Engine five. And then you will have Unreal Engine
four and then add the assets. But the problem is
you might have a lot of issues after upgrading it
back to Unreal Engine five, which is why it is
still in early access. Not a lot of assets are
still away are available for Unreal Engine five
witches. Yes, it is a little disappointing, but
at the same time, they've specifically mentioned
this engine is an early access. So don't be too
worried, you can follow the exact same tutorial
that I've showed over here in Unreal Engine four,
it's the same functionality, same blueprints, all
of them work perfectly fine, it's just that the UI
might look a little different. This looks a lot
more modern than Unreal Engine four. That's the
only difference accurate pretty much fine for
now when it comes to at least the basic parts.
So this tutorial can be followed in Unreal
Engine four, two, so don't worry about that.
But thank you so much for watching. I
really hope you learned something and I hope
you were able to familiarize yourself with
Unreal Engine five and game development.
If you've completed this course that is amazing
tied to add your own functionality to it.
If you want to learn C++ stay tuned because
I have a C++ course coming very, very soon
we're going to create the exact same game
but in C++ so that is going to be very,
very fun. But thank you so much for watching
and I will see you very soon. Bye and good luck.